it's been five years half a decade since
breath of the wild released and guess
what yep you guessed it i've got more
things for you if you continue to enjoy
this series and want to see more from us
let us know with like alright here we go
one of the biggest new discoveries found
this year is item transmutation allowing
you to turn any material into something
else buy item hold smuggling five
materials into your hands selling the
rest off so you have none left it
carries over the holding 5 item's value
onto whatever stackable material you
want
including korok seeds and shrine orbs
this is the first discovery of srm also
known as stale reference manipulation in
breath of the wild although nothing
nearly as game breaking as something you
would see in ocarina of time
you've seen triforce designs everywhere
especially at the temple of time the
front and rear walls the floor it's
pretty hard to miss but there's one that
you might not have really seen if you
take a closer look at the floor of the
building in front of the temple there's
a signature of din the triforce of power
looking at the floor of the other two
you'll find barely legible symbols of
nehru and feyror as well these three on
the map all laid out show that this is
the full triforce symbol facing
southward pointing to the entrance of
the temple of time if you can't see the
symbols clearly in breath of the wild
hop on over to age of calamity you'll
see them there plain as day
you've probably heard the music and
shrines hundreds of times before but
have you actually paid attention to how
it works on the japanese nintendo
website they explain unlike most
standard songs that loop over and over
shrines have unique music with special
quote-unquote phrases that are
randomized over the time that you're
exploring that's why when you enter the
same shrine multiple times you'll
basically never hear the exact same song
over and over
[Music]
it's a little bit tricky but these goron
pots answer the age-old question of can
you pick up something you're standing on
yes if timed perfectly link will pick up
the pot he's standing on and launch
himself into the air although i don't
think that's how that works in real life
did you know that these types of candles
can be lit
many interactable torches in hyrule
castle come unlit and can give the
sanctum a really different vibe when all
of them are turned on
did you know that bloopies conduct
electricity
link has a high resistance to fire when
it's raining such as against burning
grass but this applies to other fire
effects as well such as during a flame
lizalfo's flame breath which will have
no effect on link
most players know that fire choo choo
and keys die when exposed to rain but
most people forget that choo choo
jellies are just portable water balloons
and when struck near them have the same
effect
when selling items the menu locks you
out of weapons bow and arrows and
shields never allowing you to sell these
items but believe it or not this
equipment does have ruby value in the
game's code these buying and selling
values were likely implemented during
testing then removed in the final
product but you can still see these
values in the game's code such as a
traveler's sword worth 5 rupees to sell
and 20 to buy the savage lionel bow
worth 52 rupees and 156 to buy and the
radiant shield worth 52 rupees and 210
rupees to buy this is more of a quick
tip but many players when trying to
start a fire on a hill throw the wood
first then try to quickly light it often
rolling away rather do it the other way
around shoot the ground with the fire
arrow first then throw the wood on top
of it
it's a much faster way to ignite the
wood or a funny trick is to hold smuggle
a burning weapon then throw the wood
it'll auto light as soon as it lands
here's an older trick some players don't
know it's possible to run around with
the horse permanently on ice or on fire
by using an old method of shooting your
own horse as you drown from gliding far
away or using the new campfire method
with enemy horses you can have the horse
permanently on fire or frozen this horse
just like with similar glitches makes
him immune to fire so if you have the
patience to get the horse to death
mountain you can ride around freely in
the burning air
everyone's heard of bullet time bounces
but you can do this to certain other
items besides link the easiest way is to
wait until a bokoblin lifts a rock then
freeze it in bullet time then watch the
fireworks unfold
everyone knows that you can fire bows
while on a horseback but what you may
not have noticed is that every bow is
changed to have the exact same fire rate
this can be a buff or a nerf depending
on the bow for example the royal guards
bow has the fastest fire rate in the
game and on horseback is nerfed pretty
severely while on the other hand the
ancient bow fires relatively slow but is
increased on horseback at the special
fire rate did you know that it's
possible to damage enemies with a
backflip this is more consistent with
low-level goblins with the well-timed
backflip you can take them out unarmed
terrytown's central bell is a unique
magnetic object try using magnesis on
the bell it will actually make a ringing
noise
or shooting it with projectiles to swing
it back and forth will work as well
there were many crystals and minerals in
breath of the wild including sapphire
ruby topaz diamonds and many more but
rivali carried one more stone that's
technically in the game but was never
usable jade rivale's hair ties and
anklets are made of pure jade but jade
is found nowhere else in hyrule
have you ever wondered how the grey
plateau tower had a gaping hole in the
hill when you first found it well
apparently during the calamity 100 years
ago guardians fired straight shots into
the mount making the hole that you see
today some people still haven't noticed
that during the champions ballad dlc
cutscenes the champions all perform
their signature key art pose at some
point
out of respect for our princess you may
keep your lives these poses are also the
chosen pose for all of the champion
amiibos the final design of the ancient
blade saw is based mostly on the rough
design of a chainsaw but during
development they had a slightly
different idea with three separately
rotating blades this was probably
inspired by the real life saw like this
in a profession called aerial tree
trimming where helicopters use these
multi-rotating blades to cut trees from
above
when you fire a shock or fire arrow at
an object it will carry those properties
for a moment with the object this counts
basically any object that can be shot
such as materials your own bombs and
even rupees which slide extremely far
and can carry your fire into enemy
territory
here's some nifty things that mentions
the final boss so spoiler heads up for
any recent new players i've shown before
with a lino's fireball so you can
counter it with any ice attack but this
includes many other fireball attacks
such as the wiz ropes fireballs fire
blight's normal and shotgun style
fireball and even calamity gannon's
deadly explosive fireball right out of
his hands
breath of the wild speedrunners have
drilled this 80 trick into their head
for years stun locking ganon with a
two-handed slam over and over to cheese
gannon but did you know that nintendo
completely knew about this trick and
wrote new codes around it with the
release of master mode this trick as
many know doesn't work on master mode
and only on normal mode because of this
specific set of code here ruling out
that if the hard code manager flag aka
master mode and other small conditions
are true stun lock is patched but if
it's false then this allows players to
stun ganon over and over why is this
stun lock purposely left in the game i'm
pretty sure papa nintendo is watching
the speedrunners
happy 5 year anniversary breath of the
wild hopefully the sequel will arrive
soon where we can continue the series on
there if you enjoyed this video we still
continue to make new videos about breath
of the wild to this day so stick around
for everything else gaming keep it here
on gamespot
you